well first i want to say that the
simon's institute is a really nice place
and thank you very much for the
invitation to be here and also to
the challenge of giving this lecture
of course i will try to say something in
this lecture but i'll try not to say too
much to the
colleagues in theoretical computer
science that so nicely showed up but i
try to tell things to people who are not
in the field so i really want sort of to
create a feeling for what kind of things
we're thinking about you know tell you
some
results and also some open problems
actually that and you'll see that some
of the open problems are so easy you so
you can go home and think about them
directly
and
well the hope is that you'll understand
something so if i start losing you and
speaking too fast you know please raise
your hand and say that
ask questions i think that always adds
to the talk yeah
so
what's efficient of computation well
there's sort of a theory side and a
practice side to it and on the practice
side you in fact
run come into it every now and then
so for instance if you're in a big city
which has good public transportation the
question how to get from point a to
point b might be difficult
you expect your search engine to return
it within a second and that's sort of
doable as you you can
experience every now and then sometimes
you don't get as good answers as you
hope but that's a different point
the other sort of end of the scale is
whatever you can do in real human time
and something that's been a little bit
on the topic recently say that you know
can
anybody or say the nsa break the
aes encryption with reasonable amounts
of computation and say that's like a
thousand pcs in in
in a year saying
and this we don't know the answer to i
would guess no but nobody knows for sure
or maybe then the same knows for sure
um but what i'm you know the simon's
institute is a institute for the theory
of computation so i'll do theory for
essentially the rest of the talk
every now and then i'll say something in
practice and what's efficiency in theory
well they have a problem we have a
problem of a certain size which is
usually parameterized by number n
and we sort of ask how many elementary
computations
do you need to to perform something so
let's do something very simple you know
let's multiply two numbers that you
should think of really big you know
thousand digit or a million digits or
something like that
but i made it slides i made for five
digits
so the question is supposed to be all
you know that's one of the what we
thought was mathematics once upon a time
that you know i get you to to multiply
large numbers and suppose you multiply
two five digit numbers we we set it up
like this or at least did in sweden when
i was in
in whatever is you know middle school
or what not
and then you add it up and then if you
think about it for a while this sort of
says that the number of multiplications
additions of one digit numbers are about
four n squared where
it would be like a hundred elementary
operations doing this five by five you
know you need to multiply each digit in
one by digit in in the other and so
forth
so the question the questions we love to
study now is this the best possible or
is a more efficient way to do this
and the first thing i want to say is
well this is obviously the best possible
for multiplication okay because you have
you know n digits in the first number
you have n digits and the second number
you need to multiply each digit in this
one by the other right
how many feel that this was sort of a
proof
how many people felt that this was sort
of a fishy argument that you sort of
wasn't really
couldn't be formalized
okay
so that was a theory t-shirts you know
all the theoreticians knows that this
was completely bogus right
but some of them were a little bit
caught up no nobody did raise their
hands on the first one but
yeah
so this is completely wrong it sort of
assumes that we're going to do
multiplication the standard old way and
and sort of the name of the game is that
we don't want to do things the way we've
always done then we want to do them in a
more efficient way
so how do you do multiplication
well
for those who
have a little
bit of background i mean multiplication
is really a convolution if you think
about it if you know what convolution is
and if you don't you can
start listing at the next slide
and then you really think of your
numbers as vectors of digits you do some
fast fourier transform you multiply the
transforms and then you do an inverse
fft and then you clear up the
result okay
and in fact if you do this you have to
choose certain things you know where
you're going to do the fast fourier
transform how you're going to do the the
the multiplications of the the point by
multiplications and a few details
and
as late as 2007 you know this algorithm
was actually improved to get a better
running time and it's essentially n log
n
it's a little small factor which goes to
infinity but essentially and logan
operations and this was an improvement
there was an improvement of a previous
algorithm that was the champion for 35
years by sean hagan strass
um what i want to point out is that some
so easy operation as multiplication of
large numbers we don't know how to do it
efficiently you know we keep finding
better ways to do it
and we don't know that it's hard at all
you know
they were nowhere close in proving that
n log n is the best possible it's quite
possible that you can do it in 10 n
operations where you have n digits
in each of the numbers
um operations i mean you know
multiplications of one digit numbers
so this is the first open problem that
you can go home and think about whether
this is possible or not
i would suspect it's not but but
who knows
um
good um
so this is sort of saying you know n
squared is not so good and logan is
better and this is what would really use
utopia but
for the most of the talk i really want
to do theory theory and that sort of
saying that any function of operation
that grows
a little bit slowly within with the
running time we start with the input
size
like a polynomial is good
and even a polynomial like this which
almost doesn't appear in in practice
will be considered good but anything
that grows faster in particular
exponentials is bad
that means that the running time will
increase so quickly with the input size
that in fact we cannot do it
and the here with the green curve is 2
to the n and the blue curve it's x cubed
it's just saying that what really
matters is that you know how does
running time
increase
as the input size goes up
so let's take the favorite of all you
know problems which is the traveling
salesman problem
and you have a salesman that hears
sweden by the way norway finland denmark
and the question is he has 100 cities in
sweden he wants to visit them as quickly
as possible
and travel as little as possible
and some of you this sort of map even if
you don't see the cities gives you a lot
of intuition
but once you're in a computer you should
really think that you know you have to
give your distances and you're supposed
to compute the best way to do it
and if you i just gave the five biggest
cities and then it's sort of clear how
to find the the
the best ordering you just try with
possible orderings
that's a very quick way to do it and it
turns out that you should go from
stockholm to absolutely to gotham to you
at the boy and then to mama
okay
so let's return to our
the the situation where we had 100
cities
and then it's sort of clear
how should we do the the um
we can do the same similar things here
we can assume we start in stockholm
which you always do in sweden
and then you have 99 possibilities to
the first city to go to and then 98 for
the second
97 for the next
and then sort of if you multiply all
these numbers that's the number of
possibilities you get
okay and this seems like it would be a
pretty big number
but you don't realize exactly how big a
number it is from your until you write
it out and this is sort of the number of
possibilities we would have to try
and uh
this number for those who not experience
is of course 99 factorial with an
exclamation point
and this is something you could try in a
contract with the non-mathematician if
you are strike an exclamation point
after the the sum
and they somehow and they tell you that
they're going to pay the actual sum they
actually owe you a fair amount of money
the question is if that would stand up
in court or not but that's
well so let's think about it for a while
computers are in fact pretty fast
and the standard computer on your
desktop makes a billion operations a
second that's a
pretty big number
and if you look at tsp that in fact
tells you that even if you're a very bad
programmer you can do 14 second
cities in a second
but in fact you know if you want to do
100 cities as you
might have noticed on the previous page
this would be a large number of seconds
yeah
and now when you're thinking about
billions and lifetimes and so forth
do you expect to live in for a billion
seconds
how many people expect to live for a
billion seconds
how many
people don't expect to live for a
billion seconds
okay so hopefully most of you are wrong
because a billion seconds is 30 years
okay
so that's a that's the way it sort of
tells you a little bit about the numbers
so i i hope to have about a billion more
to go but that's
that's the way life is okay
so the fact that computers are fast i
think sort of
brings this quote to mind that i wanted
to say is which is attributed to knuth
which is one of the old men of the field
says that
you shouldn't optimize too early because
you know computers are pretty fast and
if you it's more important to get the
program correctly
and then it probably will run fast on an
actual computer
but
during my lifetime i sort of felt the
other way around maybe you know complete
absence of optimization is even worse
because i don't i sometimes i can't
understand why i have to write wait five
seconds while the computer doing
something trivial i mean it has
then in that period of time it has done
five billion operations that's a lot of
operations
so
that's a new quote okay but that's not
where we were going really
i
want to return to the traveling
statement problem
and in fact
assault by held corp i believe it is
right
also yes
prove that in fact you can do it in a
little bit better than n factorial in
time essentially two to the n
and in fact that sort of says that 25
cities is doable in a second but still
that 100 cities is still not doable in
the lifetime
and that sort of this happened in the
must have been in the 70s or 60s 70s
60s
and we haven't really improved this in
the worst case running term
and the the question that's for sort of
steps out that maybe this is best
possible maybe nature is this bad maybe
we did need these many operations
and the amazing thing is that i said
before that you know we don't know how
to do multiplication that that requires
much more time than reading the input
but in fact it's the same is true for
the traveling salesman problem
we don't know that in fact you have to
read i mean not here that the input is n
squared because we have n squared
distances here to read
so you don't know how to do more than
read the actual input that you have to
do that actually compute the best term
so this is where we're at
and
our hope to go anywhere in this world
was sort of done by forming the mp
complete problems
and i won't tell you exactly why they're
called np complete and so forth what i
want to say is that this is a family of
a very large number of computational
problems
none of them is known to be solved in
polynomial time
and they have the property that if one
of them is solvable in polynomial time
so are all of them
and this question whether none of them
or all of them are solvable in
polynomial time is the famous question
that whether mp is equal to p
and that's
well it's really the main open question
on computer science and when i started
in the 80s we
we thought we would soon solve this but
this hasn't really moved into 30 years
since i've been in the field
and
there are lots of problems that aren't
complete i wrote a couple of one i will
return to this one later but
the main thing to note here is that
the traveling salesman is one of these
problems doesn't be complete
okay
so as i said we haven't been able to
prove that mp is not equal to p but i
would like to state that you know every
reasonable research researcher in this
area believes that they're not equal
okay
and this by mathematics in fact the
tautology because anybody who believes
that they're equal is not reasonable
so that's where this quality from no but
joking apart it seems like most people
would come to the to the conclusion that
np is probably not equal to p
and
in fact it seems like an extremely
difficult problem
and the problem is that it's very hard
to prove that something requires you
know large computational research
resources
um
so really the way things have been going
is that
we simply assume that this is too true
you know we we
can't prove this as a mathematical
theorem as we would have wanted to prove
but in cell we'll say that this is a law
of nature and sort of take a physicist's
point of view
and then we
try to derive consequences of this
law of nature
so i'm not getting any objections here
which sort of makes me worried but
anybody can object and ask questions yes
yeah so that's a quantum computer i mean
the next semester at simon's institute
will be devoted partly to quantum
computing right
so
i would be extreme you know it could be
that quantum computer can solve a
complete problem it doesn't seem so
people have been thinking about these
problems for for 10 years
but let me take my next like
suppose we actually in some word
that p np actually sort of in the in a
really equals p by this i mean that you
know we have really fast algorithm all
mp complete problems that's a little bit
what you're saying
it's a it's a logically conceivable
world
and i think it's a good world in the
sense that all planning problems are
easy
it's a
it's a good or bad world in the sense
that you know to prove a theorem is
easy to verify the proof
which means we don't need as many
mathematicians
which
mean that we could either think of as a
good or a bad thing for the world
a third thing that i think is that we
have no security or privacy on the
internet which is probably a bad thing
for the world but
that's all might be a matter of taste
but yeah it could be but
i i would i would be extremely surprised
if this we're in this world i don't know
how to answer it but that's
so now i'm sort of starting to close up
on on where we're going
so
we view the world that you know np is
not equal to p that's our our
l of
turning salesman problem
is empty complete
and hence we do not think that there
will be
an algorithm that always solves it
correctly and
always runs fast
but we want to solve the problem and
then there's sort of two options to go
we write an algorithm
and we have to sacrifice something
either that it sometimes is very slow or
sometimes that it returns a not so good
solution
and both these are viable approaches but
i'm mostly interested in the second one
we want an algorithm that
always runs fast and always returns a
reasonably good solution
so let's see
the first algorithm that possibly comes
to mind
is
the way
many of us lived our lives
and said you know we do one thing at the
time and we do the one that's cheapest
for the moment
we visit a few cities and we always go
to the closest city that we haven't
visited and then we
we sort of see what result we get
and if you look at this
for instance this is very efficient you
know it's very easy to to calculate what
to do next
there are some instances where it does
work pretty well
but there are some instances where it
works less well
and now we're sort of interested to say
you know how well does it work
we need to really say what
how efficient it is to calculate but
that's sort of an easy point and the
question is how good the solution does
it return
and the dominating thing that
to evaluate this
is sort of to compute the ratio between
the solution that we find and the ratio
of the optimal solution
and
then see what guarantees we can give on
this number
so then we essentially want
to be really happy we want
two statements the first is a proof that
says that will always be pretty close to
the best value
and what happens to be the case for the
for the um nearest neighbor the great
heuristic is that your your logarithm
your at most an absolute constant times
log of the number of cities times
optimal you never do something that's
worse than this
and the second thing you want is sort of
an example saying that well this is the
best mathematical theorem around there
are in fact some instances you know some
sets of distances
where this where this factor of log n
shows up and maybe you you get a
different constant here because we can't
always prove the optimal results
and it's sort of the the jargon way to
say this is that greedy the greedy
heuristic is a theta logan this sort of
means that this is both an upper and
lower bound approximation algorithm for
t is p
and the first thing you want to ask is
this
this is very bad since when the number
of cities grows the the approximation
gets worse and worse and the first
question you ask
is there
an algorithm that gives you a ratio
that's independent on the number of
cities you you're visiting
um
and this again you know was a sort of
extremely natural question that was
around christopher's already in 1976
said well let's
see what kind of efficient algorithms we
have
he said well finding a mean cost
spanning tree is easy
finding a mean cost matching is easy
and then in fact that's all we're going
to do
so if this sketches
a little bit
too fast let me do it in pictures this
is a graph
okay
so what's a graph well these are sort of
cities
and these edges are sort of
rows between the cities they should
really have distances but i didn't put
the distances there not to clutter the
picture
so the first thing is to find the
spanning tree
so spanning tree is just a set of of
roads that in fact connects the cities
somehow it's not a tour but it sort of
connects them a little bit
and it's very efficient to find
the cheapest spanning tree you know
cheapest set to to connect them so that
you can go between all the cities
this has
this sort of has a big problem that you
need to go back and forth between these
two things so what you do is you take
the the guys of degrees one and in
particular the odd ones
and you add a matching to these
so you need to make it a little bit more
connected so you take the guys of odd
degree
and add the matching of these
which
and the union of of the
so the cost of spanning sorry this cost
of the spanning tree is never more than
the cost of the tour the cost of the
matching turns out to be at most half
the cost of the tour
and then to make it a real
tour
you just need to make shortcuts
that
this here is really looks like a tour
and the problem is you're visiting this
too many times so the second time you
want to visit it just go directly to
where you're going and that sort of
creates a nice tool
so the second homework problem i want to
give to you guys is that you now
we're having a
tsp and i want you a polynomial time
algorithm that finds an
a tour that's always a little bit better
than 1.5 saying say 1.49 okay
this is an easy homework problem and we
have been working on it for 37 years
okay
so
when i first read when i was in in grad
school i got this 1.5 algorithm i said
well we should soon be able to improve
this but nobody has been able to improve
it and people have been working more and
more aggressively on it and it's really
uh an easy to state problem that we
don't know the answer
okay
and when you go home and work on it i
just want to say that you want
something that beats effect 1.5
on every input
you know getting on something on some
nice inputs that's sort of not too hard
you also want to make sure that you know
the distances are completely arbitrary
you shouldn't for instance if you work
with you know
flying distance the distance between
points in the plane this is in fact easy
to get when not easy but it's possible
to get a factor
better than 1.5 and it's been known for
15 years now
we really want the fact 1.49 and the
only thing you can use about your
distance function is that it's replace
the triangle inequality
and this is an extremely
you know intuitive inequality it says
that going from a to c
it
it's never been it's not
worse to go directly than to go via ctb
that's that's all you may use okay
is the problem clear to you
you can deliver it
next simon's lecture and then you can
give it to me and then we i can be a
co-author
okay but
where we're going
if
you can't solve this homework problem
it's maybe 1.5 is the best possible
constant
and
we note here that if it's going to be
the
best possible constant then in fact we
have to assume that mp is not equal to p
because if mp is equal to p then in fact
we can solve it optimally okay
and but this is a law of nature so i
i'll well i'll state this every now and
then to remind you that we have this
little nature but
and what turns out is that well we can't
do but we can do something and it turns
out that
we can prove that you cannot get very
close to optimum at least you have to be
off by almost a percent
unless np is equal to p
this is
this constant has been going up slowly
and slowly and this is a result like
karpinsky lumpys
i forget my message who else is at this
point but
uh
from this year so this is a
slow improvement but there's a
substantial gap
yeah
for the moment that's all i wanted to
say about
traveling salesman problem i'll return
to it in the end anybody wants to
ask something about tsp
yes
yes yeah no the i'm
making a huge over simplification there
are lots of complexity classes right
some between p and p and they're there
and on above mp there's always a
tremendous number of complexity classes
so yes there are lots of classes
well this is of course a matter of
personal taste right which problems are
interesting but i think np is really the
basic i mean it captures all these
planning problems and optimization
problems that show up in practice
so it's my favorite class and some of
their more difficult problems but
we can't
we can't
we have to get get to extremely
extremely difficult problems before we
can actually prove that they're
difficult there's a complex class p
space which is above which is bigger
than np and also those we can't prove is
hard
but if you get yes
what about between p and p like n to the
fifth
yeah
precisely time into the fifth
for example i mean that's absurd no it's
not absurd it's good good time
um
yes no better than two to the end
yes i have to agree with this
uh
no i completely agree i'm i'm
we at the the
we'll just wait for simons to not donate
money to this
practical
no no of course yeah no so being more
serious
i mean i love this question about
multiplication right so we can't even
prove that multiplication can't be done
in linear time
and proving that anything
i'm distinguishing them to the fifth you
know
that would be great i mean proving that
so yeah
but we can't
answer eve in this very course question
right and once we've answered those i
would be extremely happy to see a proof
that mp is not
you know
not contained in n squared time right so
well it doesn't raise a question about
the nature of the reduction so i guess
the question is how
sort of how much of the efficiency does
this reduction
is there a classification of better
reduction versus worse for example yes
there is
but yeah so
so this
what mike is referring to is that we
have all these uh you know np complete
problems that are similar complexity the
question is well there's a big
difference between two to the n and two
to the square root n and but and this
has been studied and that would be you
know
i'm giving you an extremely simple black
and white picture which should be
refined in many ways i agree
yes you remember
but i'm happy for questions
yeah so i'm sorry i stopped this so now
i want to go to another favorite
people
question for for com
for complexity theories and that's
formulas over boolean variables
and boolean variables i'll denote by x
with a little index down which is called
x sub i and this is sort of this is in a
bar of it is the negation that sort of
says you should treat it the other way
turn true into false and false into true
and um
this little thing is a logical and this
thing is a logical ore
so i'll just to get the the this thing
straight
we have two drivers alice is driving
left
going west sorry on the left-hand side
going west that's sort of what x1 says
so if x1 is true this is true and if x1
is false she's driving on the right hand
side i'm well i'm
well i'm cheating you slightly there but
this sort of means that she's on the
left-hand side and the complement would
be just on the right hand side and this
same is for bob
and he's going the other direction
and the fact they're not colliding is
sort of saying that they're both on the
left or they're both on the right right
and both on the left says that x1 and x2
is true
and that they're both on the
right means that they it's both sure
that x1 is false and x2 is false and
that sort of says that there's no
collision
anybody who's not a computer scientist
that's happy with this
that's unfortunate
if you're unhappy with this and want to
understand it please ask a question
right this is sort of a boolean variable
that says something is true or false and
this says that x1 and x2 is true which
says that alice drives on the left going
east bob drives on the left going
going
sorry going west and bob is going east
so this says that they're both drying on
the left they're in the uk
and they're not colliding right
here says that they're both driving on
the right they're in the us and they're
not colliding
so this is that they're both in the uk
and then you can sort of play around
with these logical formulas and you can
sort of
it turns out that this is logically
expressing exactly the same thing as you
negate one of the variables you move the
words around and you put an and between
them and you have the and of two little
orders of size two
and now you immediately can go to bigger
formulas and say you know
and now i have five different variables
i have the answer lots of little small
things which is each the order of three
variables and the question is can you
satisfy all these constraints at the
same time what do you think mike
i mean you should you first encourage
questions and then you and then you then
you're wishes to the people that ask
questions
right that's that's the way to proceed
in class you know for those
questions yeah yeah that's the point
so you just stay at these things for a
while
and then say that yeah in fact
you can't satisfy all the constraints
here's the five variables and you can
check that this actually works out okay
so now we're interested in this these
kind of formulas
and
this is this called the sat problem you
have to do some notation
the formula just had this on something
called conjunctive normal form
and it has a parameter k which says that
the number of guys in each or
so this is the three cnf formula that i
had on the previous slide and the
satisfiability of formulas on the three
cnf formulas called three set
and we're interested in satisfying such
formulas
and this one was essentially the first
problem to be
proved to be np-complete it's
computational difficult
given a formula like this to try to to
see if there's a satisfying assignment
and he also here i want to relax it and
say
let's instead look at trying to satisfy
as many
constraints as possible
okay
so the game is now that i give you a
formula like this which you should think
of as much larger but pretty large
and you i some just for some reason you
might assume that there's some
assignment that satisfy all these
constraints that you want to find
some assignment that satisfy as many
constraints as possible
okay
and
and whenever you're going to see how
well an algorithm works here we have a
very nice algorithm which is really
thinking as little as possible
okay
so don't even look at the formula it's a
big complicated ugly thing
right
not too many have probably read this for
millennia
and you just set each variable randomly
to true or false with equal probability
you just flip a random coin and say well
x1 should be true x 2 should be false
and so forth
and this has the pretty good property
well look at this constraint it says
that x1 should be true or x2 should be
true or x3 should be true
so this you have three shots at making
this true and sort of with
probability 7 8 you'll in fact make that
constraint true just
flipping things randomly
and this gives in fact an approximation
algorithm with the approximation ratio
of 7 8.
the funny thing is that this is the best
you can do
this completely stupid algorithm is the
best approximation algorithm you can get
for for for this problem which is called
max three set
so if i give you any number that's
greater than 7 8 which is 0.875 like
0.876
it's n it's unless mp is equal to p you
can't find such an
assignment efficiently
okay
so it really says that threesat
which we
felt originally was a bit complicated is
extremely complicated we can't do
anything
that's a little bit efficient here
i happen to have a student that does a
living and solving three set formulas
but that's all relating more to that
instances in the real world are small
and computers are fast but in theory you
can't do it
so let's go for something simpler where
we actually can do something and suppose
we still have boolean variables and i
just ask that the only type of
constraint you can have that some
variable is not equal to some other
variable
that's the only type of constraints i
will allow
and let's at the same time introduces
different problems which i call max cut
and it's sort of given that i give you a
graph
here with blown nodes and connections
between
the nose and the question is divide this
into two pieces so that whenever two
things are connected we want them to
have different colors
it's called max cut because it's cutting
the the graph into two pieces to cut all
the edges
okay
and here i made sort of a way to do this
you know i call it half or some fraction
of them red and
in a smart way to try to cut as many
edges as possible
so let's see if i can get what's
if i had this problem and i had this
problem on the previous slide you see
any connection between them
for a non-theoretical computer scientist
here
does any theoretical computer scientists
see a connection between the two
problems
no
it's the same problem right
yeah an edge is just a
thing that two things should be
different under the different is blue is
sort of corresponding to true and red is
false
and it's really the same problem
sure
well
i give you boolean
variables and i should ask them not to
be equal
one should be true that one should be
false
so you want a solution
yeah or as many as you can if you can't
get all you should get
yeah but max cut yeah
optimization problem and decision
problem but it's really right
you want the color red is
false blue is true you connect two
things
okay
so this is easy so as
because if you start saying that this
should be blue that in fact all its
neighbors should be red
so if you want to satisfy if you want to
cut all the edges is in fact extremely
simple to cut all the edges
but it gets very tricky if you just want
to cut 99 of the edges
the question can we find such a cut
can we find something that's almost
perfect so that almost all the the the
edges have endpoints of different color
and
what i wanted to describe next is an
efficient algorithm for doing this okay
that in fact this problem is so simple
that we can do it
it took us 20 years to come up with the
right id and this was done by german
williamson and i'm the hope is to
convince you of this right idea
that
in fact if you think if you change true
and false for plus minus one and e is
the set of edges which is just a set of
constraints we're trying to optimize
this this
mathematical sum
so german williamson's great idea was
that we should make this simpler we
should you know take this product and
introduce a new variable
instead
which makes this a lot easier to
maximize since we don't have any
constraints
uh
but the the key constraint here is to
prove that
to to cl want the y variables to form a
positive sum of matrix with ones on the
diagonal which is sort of not
such a
this gets a little bit technical so
there
but i'm just trying to give you a flavor
of these things
so what's the positive semi-definite
matrix well it's a matrix which is all
eigen if it's symmetric which it's
assumed to be
that it's
all positive eigenvalues
that in fact as viewed as a quadratic
form is strictly posit or it's
non-negative
and in fact it can be factorized as a
matrix
the transpose of a matrix from the
original matrix
and this is this in fact true
the original solution is just the
special case when x is the
y is the product of vector and transpose
okay
and it turns out that this relaxation
you can in fact
solve efficiently
and in fact you can optimize any
linear function of of the
coefficients in the matrix giving any
set of linear constraints
and the intuitive reason this is true is
that the set of positive semi-different
matrices is convex and and
you're optimizing a linear function over
a convex set and it has no local optima
so some kind of steepest descent should
do it
if you study sleep is the center but
let's ignore this sketch if you're
not familiar with these
things so backing up i mean the
alternative way to propose this is that
you're trying to maximize something like
this when the x's are plus minus ones
and instead you you say you want to
optimize this
where this is an inner product between
two vectors of unit length
so we're relaxing the optimization
problems from from sort of the real line
to the to n-dimensional real space
and
this enables us to be able to solve the
problem
so the vector problem in fact is easy to
solve
and we get a higher objective value and
the key problem is now how do we take a
solution to the vector
to the vector problem and make it a
boolean solution
and what thomas and williamson realized
apart from we should do it like this is
that an extremely simple to round the
vector solution
to a plus minus one solution and that's
just to pick a random vector and
and let x i be the sign of the inner
product
and the reason this works is that if any
two vectors that give a good
contribution
to the relaxed problem
it's extremely likely that the sign of
the two vectors are different i try to
indicate this by the vector the two
vectors
and sort of the bad directions where
where
where these signs are different or sort
of this
narrow cone here and a random vector
over here for instance will give
a good boolean solution that satisfy the
corresponding constraint
and trying to put this intuition in
mathematical terms you just make a
variable for the angle between the
vectors
the contribution to the objective
function is one minus cos cosine of this
vector over two
the probability that the two things are
cut is the vector over pi
and the minimal quotients of this gives
the approximation algorithm for the
government some williamson
algorithm
so since i i don't do as much algorithms
as
hardness results i'm really saying you
know well we have this great algorithm
that was approached
proposed in the mid 90s is this best
possible
and i try to prove that it's not so far
and i got the lower bound that you can't
at least do 16 over 17. that's
and then this has sort of been standing
still for an extremely long time but
then in 2004
these two set of authors started
something called the unique games
conjecture and prove that
in fact if that conjecture is true
then the gramason william constant is
optimal and this is sort of at least a
50 50 proposition at this stage of the
game
um
well m here is m el hanan mosulu
introduced me so i should be a little
bit nice at least to mention his point
in my name
so what so the thing i want to tell you
about is the unique games conjecture is
one of the few things that
and
so which is sort of the third homework
problem
and this is that i give you a lodge into
the ram
and
i say that now we should have variables
that take values in
0 to minus 1 and i give you very simple
linear equations modem
so this sort of says that when you take
x 1 and add 11 you should get x 3 more
than so if this is greater than m you
subtract them
so this is linear equations more than
with two variables in each equation
which is
a problem denoted by this
and the question now is that suppose i
promise you that you can so not solve
all of these then it's sort of easy but
you can satisfy 99 of these equations
or i'm giving you an extremely difficult
instance of this where you can only
satisfy one percent can you tell which
one it is
and that's it's
essentially the unique games conjecture
okay
so i give you an extremely simple set of
equations for them
and
and sort of 99 is really any number
smaller than 100 and this is greater
than
zero
and this is a computational problem
that's really been with us for the last
10 years
and it's more and more open as time goes
by
various algorithm has been proposed none
works for all instances
on the other hand whenever people come
up with an ensemble of instances there's
always an algorithm that seems to solve
them
so
it's sort of a war between these two
fronts and we need some new idea to be
able to to to solve the unique games
instances
yeah so let me as a final point return
to the traveling salesman problem you
know
as i told you before
it's you can approximate it between
1.5 you can't do something
1.01 essentially
and you know question are we happy you
know or
is this really what we want to achieve
and some people said well yeah it's
within a constant and who cares about
this constant
and i sort of the other way around say
you know this is an exciting constant of
nature and we have to find out what it
is
but
even if you're not
so much into detail let's look at the
closely related problem and say that
we have the traveling salesman problem
where it's might be more expensive to go
from a to b than b to a
you know you might be
up in the hills for instance in berkeley
hills and it's much easier to go to work
than to go home
and
then it turns out that the approximation
algorithm across the feeds doesn't work
and the state of the art there is that
the best algorithm is almost like greedy
for
the the standard one is off by
essentially a factor login
the hardness results gets a little bit
better but not much
and the question which of these two
is the correct answer
and my view is well historically we've
always been better at finding algorithms
and analyzing them and proving hardness
but only at the end here the situation
is extremely picky in the sense that you
know we do have an algorithm
but
proposed by helton carp and it's been
around now for 50 years
and we don't know
if it's this bad or it might give the
answer within a factor of two
so usually the hard question is to try
to find a good algorithm but here the
question is you know hey we have the
algorithm we just don't know how good it
is we know it's fast but we don't know
the quality of the result
so what have i been trying to do this
you know lecture
well i've been trying to
tell you about approximation problems so
and for some of these problems we know
uh
the answer for like max 3 sat you know
the rock bottom algorithm that gave 7 8
was the is the best one and we can prove
that this is the case
i gave you some other problems
like asymmetric tsp standard tsp and max
cut
and in fact we don't really understand
what's going on there
if we assume this strain is probably
unique games conjecture then max cut is
resolved but these two other we still
don't get any
better results for them
so
we can go home and work on all three of
these and
well that's what i wanted to say
any more questions or comments
yeah well now i won't lecture anymore so
i can't
i promise not to ask any embarrassing
country questions yes thank you
well if you're so if you're looking at a
fairly natural problem there's many
people that have you know these basic
problems that are sort of easy to state
probably somebody already looked at the
problem
yeah i mean you you should
that's
well yeah you should maybe that's yeah
google the problem that's
so for instance i had to google to find
the best constant for the proximability
of the tsp you know it keeps improving
all the time so google is actually a
good and google i'm proud to say sort of
came out a little bit of theory of
computation
if we're sort of stretching things a
little bit not too much but a little
bit okay